[Music]
foreign
people have said that the eyes are
windows into the soul well that's poetic
but how do these windows allow us to
perceive the world around us
hi I'm rich Burnett for wandrium and in
this episode of perspectives five
experts delve into the world of vision
from how we experience sight to the
biology of how we interpret those
signals in our brain
let's begin now with a crash course on
the mechanics of how our eyes actually
work
foreign
how much do the mechanics of vision play
a part in our perception and therefore
our experience of the world
well quite a bit to understand it we
need to start with the physiology of
seeing
let's assume we are talking about a
healthy person with two eyes an average
vision
first the ability to see involves a
two-step process
we experience Sensations in our eyes
that are translated to Perceptions in
our brain sensations perceptions
two different things that both
contribute to the phenomenon we think of
as seeing
let's start with the sensation part the
part that happens in your eyes
everything we see starts with light in
fact the only thing we ever see from a
sensation standpoint is light and our
eyes are exquisitely built to gather it
and respond to it
the cornea Iris lens and retina make up
the anatomy of our eyes
the retina contains light sensitive
tissue
light passes through the cornea and is
bent or refracted through the pupil in
the iris and onto the lens
the lens in your eye is responsible for
taking the refracted light that passes
through your cornea and adjusting its
refraction so that the image is in focus
when it hits your retina
the cornea itself already does a lot of
the focusing as it bends the light to
pass through the iris
but the curvature of the cornea is
relatively static it doesn't change
based on the distance of what you're
viewing
to accommodate different focal lengths
we need let the lens
the lens is surrounded by muscles which
contract or relax based on the distance
of your view
if you're looking at something far away
these muscles are relaxed allowing the
lens to flatten and bend the light less
if you're looking at something close up
the muscles contract rounding the lens
and increasing the refraction
all of this is happening in less than
the blink of an eye with no conscious
effort from you until you reach your 40s
at least
the retina is the location of
photoreceptor cells which contain
proteins called opsins that detect light
opsins are transmembrane proteins
coupled to G proteins the distinctive
feature of opsins is that they hold a
molecule of vitamin A that gets altered
when exposed to light
thanks to options photoreceptor cells
detect light and pass signals on to
other neurons called ganglion cells the
axons of the ganglion cells are bundled
into the optic nerve which routes the
information ultimately back to the
visual cortex in the brain to process
the signals and tell us what we are
seeing
there are two types of retinal
photoreceptor cells involved in light
detection
rods and cones
rods are responsible mostly for
detecting light under the very low light
conditions
they provide little color information
since they are optimized to detect
things in very dim light
what Rod cells lose in color detection
they gain insensitivity a rod cell can
detect a single Photon of light
color detection is the domain of the
cone cells humans have three types of
cone cells each specialized to absorb
wavelengths Accord corresponding to red
green or blue light
cone cells operate best in bright light
the Workhorse of both the rod and The
Cone cells is a molecule called retinol
your body makes retinol first from
beta-carotene a pigment that gives
carrots orange color
your body then converts that
beta-carotene into vitamin A and
subsequently into a molecule called
retinol
what's special about retinol is that it
has a carbon chain that can take two
different configurations CIS retinol and
trans retinol chemists call that two
different isomers
they're different physical shapes of the
same chemical formula
in its usual configuration in the eye
retinol takes What's called the CIS
conformation
you see how this is a regular zigzag
carbon chain for carbons at position 7 8
9 10 and 11 but at Carbon number 12 it
takes a Bend
that bend is why this is called the CIS
conformation
cyst comes from a Latin root meaning on
the same side off of each carbon in the
chain is a side group those are things
like the hydrogen atoms when two side
groups in a row are on the same side of
the chain that's called a CIS
configuration
here you can see where the hydrogens
associated with carbon atoms number 11
and number 12 are on the same side of
the chain so at that Bond we have a CIS
configuration
the other isomer of retinol is called
trans retinal
in this configuration the zigzag no
longer takes a Bend it's been
straightened out into its trans retinal
conformation it's called trans because
now the hydrogens are on opposite sides
of the double bond between carbon atoms
number 11 and number 12. in fact the
longer name is all trans retinol since
the side groups alternate sides along
the entire chain
the key to vision is that absorption of
a photon in the right energy range
converts the retinal molecule from its
usual bent configuration which is the
CIS form into the straightened out trans
configuration
this shape change for retinol also
changes the rhodopsin holding it
resulting in activation of an
intracellular g-protein called
transducin
the next few steps involve sodium ion
channels in the absence of a signal
these channels are kept open to allow
sodium ions to move across the membrane
when activated as a result of light
detection transducin causes an enzyme
called
cgmp
phosphodiesterase to catalyze breakdown
of the molecule propping open the Gated
sodium ion channels and calcium ion
channels
keep the channel open molecule is called
cgmp or cyclic GMP and it's normally
present in the cone and Rod cells in the
absence of a light signal
in other nerve signaling you have seen
it's the opening of the sodium channels
that initiates the nerve signal
here is the closing of the channels that
starts the signal
anyway each detection of Light by a
photoreceptor leads to cyclic GMP within
it being broken down by the activated
cgmp phosphodiesterase and the gates to
the sodium and calcium channels close
this has the opposite effect from what
you have seen before
instead of an opening of ion Gates that
leads to depolarization what we have is
the closing of gates sodium and calcium
are not able to enter and we have
hyperpolarization of the membrane
this hyperpolarization triggers
Downstream signaling that ultimately
relays information to the brain which
assembles this information from all the
photoreceptors and paints the pictures
for us that amount to vision
the information that streams from the
retina through the optic nerve requires
massive decoding in order to generate
visual consciousness
that decoding takes place through a
number of steps at a number of different
places in the brain
an optic nerve leaves each eye
they meet at the optic chiasma and there
the information is sorted into two
batches
information from the left side of each
retina the left side of each visual
field is rooted to the right hemisphere
of the brain
information from the right side of each
retina the right side of each visual
field is rooted to the left hemisphere
of the brain
on each side of the brain that divided
information from the retinas is
transferred via the lateral geniculate
nucleus a way stationed in the thalamus
to the back of the brain put your hand
over the back of your head and you've
put it over the occipital lobe of the
brain
that's the visual cortex and that's
where the decoding of the message from
your eyes really begins
even there processing doesn't happen all
at once
different areas of the visual cortex
have been found to process different
aspects of the stream of information
from the retinas with quite different
effects
the first area of information arrival is
known as V1 visual processing area one
that's the area of your brain that comes
closest to an inner screen
a map of retinal impulses is laid out
over V1 though the map's a bit distorted
it tends to map things out in ways that
correspond to the intensity of
information coming in from the eyes
since information is most intense in the
fovea or the area of focus a greater
area of V1 is devoted to that area the
representation that appears on V1 is
laid out like what you see in a fisheye
mirror
V1 is just the first stop
in the adjoining area V2 stereo vision
is processed putting together the
information from two eyes to generate
your impression of a three-dimensional
scene
V3 is a distinct area that processes
depth and distance
V4 is devoted to color V5 to motion and
V6 is at work processing the position of
objects
one of the things that you see is where
things are
another thing you see is what they are
researchers often refer to a wear path
identifying spatial location as starting
in V1 and proceeding through V2 V3 V5
and V6
the wet path goes from V1 to V2 and V4
but it doesn't stop there processing
continues further into the brain each
area having a specific role there are at
least 30 distinct areas in the brain
devoted to different aspects of visual
processing
in a very real sense then the visual
scene of which you are conscious doesn't
come from the eyes
it's a result of a complex of multiple
bits of decoded information assembled
from very different areas of the brain
impossible figures and drawings
illustrate everyday challenges we face
when trying to move from Sensation to
perception
it's not as simple as just perceiving
what we see or hear or feel in the world
sometimes this sensory input can be
perceived or interpreted in different
ways
early in the 20th century so-called
Gestalt psychologists were among the
first to study how the mind organizes
Sensations into a perceptual Gestalt the
German word meaning form or shape
they recognize that we automatically
organize isolated objects we see in the
world to form more cohesive holes
the most fundamental Gestalt principle
of organization is our ability to
distinguish an object from its
surroundings
the figure from the ground
black and white images are often used to
illustrate surprising switches between
what is perceived as foreground and what
is perceived as background
one classic illustration of the figure
ground problem can be perceived as two
black silhouettes of people facing each
other with a white background in between
them but the same image can
alternatively be seen as a white vase
with the black on either side appearing
as the background
images that allow for more than one
possibility show how our perception
organizes what we see
a more difficult version of this
perceptual switching occurs in images
cleverly constructed to allow you to
perceive two different figures within
the same region while the background
region remains unchanged
one famous example portrays one image of
a young woman neck exposed looking away
while the other is of an old woman in
profile with a larger face and a much
larger nose and Chin
in both of these examples the brain is
sorting out how to define the figure the
thing to focus on and how to define the
ground the things to ignore
okay on to the other Gestalt principles
which are a little more straightforward
the second Gestalt principle that
operates during perception is closure
the idea of closure is simply that our
brains want to close open-ended forms or
fill in gaps if there are pieces missing
the next principle continuance is the
idea that we will always follow visual
lines curves or sequences as we try to
make perceptive sense of something
this principle is so strong that our
eyes will follow a path a river a fence
or horizon line right off the map so to
speak literally out of the frame of an
image
the fourth principle The Law of common
fate suggests that your brain visually
perceives two or more things moving in
the same direction as basically one unit
think of a group of geese traveling in v
formation across an afternoon sky
your brain doesn't perceive that image
as five or seven or nine different geese
it perceives that image as a single
flock of geese a v of geese even one
thing
the principle of similarity is while
similar to Common Faith but instead of
our brains using motion and direction to
establish Unity they use similarities in
forms colors patterns or other
attributes
our brains do not see 150 individual red
apples sitting in the grocery store they
see a pile of apples all red all roughly
the same shape
we don't really see two identical argyle
socks we see a pair of socks
finally the last Gestalt principle of
perception proximity
proximity is simply the idea that things
that are close to one another are part
of one group this has nothing to do with
direction or form or color or anything
else you can take any random collection
of items put them in close proximity to
one another but separate from anything
else like in a stack or a pile and your
brain won't look at it and say hey look
at that paper clip banana Fedora
magazine and shoelace
no the law of proximity says that your
brain will automatically try to organize
that image as one thing hey look at that
thing that piley thing what is that
thing
one fundamental question is whether our
ability to organize sensory information
is innate or whether this ability
develops over time with experience in
the world
people who are blind from birth but
later undergo surgery and gain the
ability to see suggests that some visual
abilities such as the ability to see
color result from fundamental biological
processes
but other abilities such as recognizing
objects seem to require experience in
the world
studies using animals have shown that
without early exposure to normal visual
experiences
such as when an animal's eyelids are
sewn shut from birth
certain parts of the brain fail to
develop even when their ability to see
is restored
this finding suggests that early visual
experiences during the first few months
of Life the critical period help guide
the development of neural Connections in
the brain
so at least for vision it appears you
need to use it or lose it or at least
use it soon or lose it
organizing sensory information from the
world into coherent and meaningful units
is obviously an important part of
perception
but perhaps the most fundamentally
important part of perception is the
final stage how we interpret that
information
your perceptual abilities would enable
you to recognize the shape of a person
standing outside your door one afternoon
but it's the interpretation of that
person's intent are they selling Girl
Scout cookies soliciting a donation
promoting their religious faith that
would influence whether you'd open the
door
thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
now on wandria